هؤلاء كانوا يفعلون ذلك باعتقادك بحكم
وظيفتهم العسكريه او بناء على تشف معين
حقد معين غل لاي سبب كان
كان يوجد من الطرفين من الطرفين من
الطرفين
ماذا طائفي او مذهبي
ربما
طبقي طبقي ما بتصور يعني لانه كان السجناء
مختلف الطبقات المجتمع يعني بالعكس
الاخوان المسلمين اغلبهم ميسورين يعني
اهاليهم ميسورين يعني المدن
بعض الاتين حضرتك ذكرت مثل عن احد الاطباء
في السجن من العساكر اللي كان عنده خاصه
كثير على حي حاله خاصه كثير وهي موجوده
وحقيقيه وكانت في جامعه حلب
بس يعني بالاساس
ممكن ان يوجد من كل التنويعات اللي حكيت
عنها
دفعته كان دفعته كلهم
بواسطه السجان يعني احيانا يسلط عليه سجان
يعني بس فيما يتعلق بالحقد يعني كان الحقد
الطائفي واضح احيانا لانه في حاله ال14
قتيل لحضرتك ذكرتها بالروايه لها علاقه
بالمقدم الذي اتى الى السجن وكان تلقى
تهديدا في الخارج وبناء عليه قتل ال14
شخصا وفي حاله الطبيب
السجان او طبيب السجن الذي قتلت اثنين
فيصل غانم ايوه قتله عباره كان عنده مسدس
بمجرد انه تلقى تحديدا
يتخلص يتخلص من كل من يعرفه
بسبب عقده نقص شخص عقده نقص
قصه طويله عريضه يعني
بالنسبه للمساجين ما كتير واضحه يعني لانه
كان المفروض تحكي مع الطبيب نفسه ويقول لك
هي عباره عن تخمينات يعني بس بعض الناس من
دفعته قبل ما يقتلهم حكوا للاخرين انه هذا
كان معناه وهذا يبدو حاقد عم بيقتل
زملائنا او قتل زميلنا الفلاني قتل زميلنا
الفلاني فبصير عدد السجناء الاخرين
عمليه تحليل وتركيب يعني بيحللوا انه هذا
السبب هو اللي خلى هذا الطبيب يسلك هذا
السلوك